We can contrast the results from the company's formal product feedback...
...with the results I found in informal conversations.
There is a remarkable difference in both the type and quality of feedback from these two methods.
Do you think it's possible for anyone to achieve this kind of result through informal customer feedback?
Frankly speaking, yes.
Informal feedback is really simple to get.
There is nothing complex about the method.
The essential point is that you have to create a space for it during meetings or conversations with clients.
The feedback is certainly an improvement over the formal feedback.
Exactly!
Let me reiterate. It's critical to be open to hearing client feedback.